[Musique]
bonjour bonjour
maïté quel joli invités nous avons là
l'homme un joli petit kosor le véritable
cochons du pays basque le vrai de vrai
une véritable race alors c'est une rare
qui disparaissait complètement où il
faudra récupérer
voilà rattrapé les protégés maintenant
et cet élevage où ce petit est né
oui a commencé en 1987 voilà oui alors
la maman qui s'appelle fantaisie un joli
je crois que je ne venais une star comme
vous non les petits sans notion
d'agriculture et l'ama la mer c'était la
véritable star du salon de l'agriculture
parce qu'elle est très belle et c'est
une race pure du pays basque alors elle
a eu six petits pour nous apprendre l
anglais parce que c'était sa première
formulée c'est cette petite cure 25
jours elle l a à peu près un an et demi
et tout ça va vivre en pleine liberté
dans les pyrénées voilà se nourrir comme
yves où droit dans une voile valideront
et ils termineront leur vie en mangeant
des glands gens tout ce qu'ils trouvent
soulignait il ya de plus naturel bon et
ça nous donne un jambon etc saint
germain comme ça tout le contraire
décidé jambon du pays des landes qui est
ovale et quitteront tandis que la
septième en ovale qui est très joli et
un peu plat et un peu plein voilà c'est
pas du tout le même genre que jamais
indécis que jamais devenu référent aussi
mais alors quelle embrouille de couleur
il a été frotté avec koala avait du
piment d'espelette
dix ans plus tard soit le cancer ça le
protège des bêtes des mouches mais il
sèche très très bien avec ça et alors là
qu'est ce que vous avez embrassé par ouf
voilà ça c'est des saucissons et on
appelle ça le bon dieu chez vous dans
les lan wan à parce que ça c'est une
triple comme on dit il ya les tripes et
à le bouder et là il ya un modèle
beaucoup plus grand après le bon dieu
ici dans les landes on ne remplit de
sang comme le bouder mais il est il est
beaucoup plus gros tandis que là il est
séché il a quand même eu trois ou quatre
mois de séchage et oui mais je vois rire
alors là bas dans les adultes il
appelait ça non pas le bon dieu mais ne
pas figer dit le petit jésus ou l'agro
jésus dans lequel des deux en tout cas
fait beau hélas que c'est cet essai que
ces 1 200 nouvelles c'est très bon alors
qu'est ce qu'on va faire aujourd'hui
vous ai parlé la mariage qu'on célébrait
des neuf voilà alors en vain marié
et le l'aquitaine aquitaine et à la
demande allemande voilà on fait l'europe
en fait la demande et pourquoi pas ce
qu'on va faire un rôti de porc avec du
porc des aldudes whipper basque avec des
fruits selon une recette danoise adapté
à l'iphone avec des kiwis et des pompes
vers vous allez nous montrer ça je
prends ma pièce de porcs de la route
dans le groupe c'est les baies de
genièvre plusieurs poivre voilà des
poivres des baies de genièvre
différentes et ses baies roses très bien
alors je roule ma pièce comme ceux ci la
voyez à ce gabarit ou et je tapote et on
va rouler là comme ceci et je vérifie si
les voilà on obtenait un peu et voilà
alesi avait l'habitude de faire ça m'a
dit et vous versez votre cher que kiki
gould tel choix futurs jeux mais ça va
tenir quand même oui voilà un bon petit
ne vous voyez ces prêts faciles que vous
dites suis si on peut faire un petit
devient serré et puis ça y est j'ai même
pas besoin de couper la corde et ensuite
il est prescrit ou pas encore
alors je vais le rouler à nouveau dans
second s'est laissé wallace est alors la
différence avec les autres français
les danois eux easy pic des coûts de
girofle dedans et vous dans les landes
en aquitaine vous emmènera de leïla et
tout le monde d'allah oui tandis que et
baisse et des coûts de girofle voyez ce
qui doit donner un goût délicieux
dérivés bien sûr ils vont mettre pas mal
je crois qu'en fait pas mal et voilà et
que fait on maintenant à alors j'ai mis
de la graisse de canard dans la cocotte
oui voilà aso fait aujourd'hui bien
entendu elle grésy elle doit être bien
et je vais aimer reprenons reçu deux
dames tout simplement lui jure bien sûr
et pain cuit
d'or bière voie lactée de rodières on va
s'occuper de nos fruits
vous avez coupé des pommes après les a
rappelés et évidemment et vous terminez
avec des kiwis betioui et que lui
d'aquitaine de chez nous voilà très bien
la vallée de l'adour bon et après qu'est
ce qui va les faire
je prends du citron vert oui je vais
serrer le jus sur ses fruits
ça va faire un bon petit mélange bien
sûr avant d'êtres humains juin tiff
injurié il ramènera quantité abouti oui
il ya bien des fruits voilà aller
allons-y gaiement
qu'est ce que vous allez en faire alors
vous allez voir je prends ma cocotte ou
mauro pini cuisse gentiment où il donne
sa couleur des jarrets jolie des rémois
se faire et se faire tout ça fait don
alors je mets mes fruits unique autour
de surobi
oui voilà et ça va prendre bien angoula
ça va me parfumer le second pis divine
ma bière vous couvrez jeu le recouvre et
vous allez laisser mijoter combien
d'heures bien passé mais vous savez
c'est padres entre 1h30 et 2h voilà
qu'est ce qu'on va faire pendant ce
temps les côtes de porchères culture
c'est une recette très ancienne au oui
c'est manger faire si votre quand même
ma grand mère ma mère gens fermés avant
mon enfant mon fils de tout le monde
c'est toute la famille devant demain je
la grammaire aussi parce que c'est pas
cher pour la côte de psa n'est pas
encore alors qu'est ce qu'il vous faut
pour le faire il nous faut des côtes de
porc bien entendu il nous faut du
vinaigre des tomates de l'oignon de
l'échalote de l'aïe
dès qu'on est chaud et salieri et c'est
tout alors montré marc alors essaie on
saisit la viande on ne l'a cuit pas on a
saisi seulement vous mettez crois oui je
m'entraîne bien sûr on marie verlinde
dans la poêle je vais la salle et le
poivre et katmandou
voilà
la jolie ses côtes rés c'est l'autre
joly au port noir et rouge des abus ce
mot et sa retraite alors on va la
laisser dorer juste un petit peu pas de
couleur oui mais voilà ça change de
couleur et bien sûr saler poivrer
l'autre côté et je les sors mais faut
pas que c'est dans le merveilleux venant
bien sûr que non mais ça déjà donné un
petit jeu un peu d'eux un petit goût
voilà qu'elles ont été saisis aux juges
au fond du jus et voilà et je l'aimé l'a
ensuite vous allez préparer le fond de
sauce bien sûr dans la même point bien
sûr et un jus des côtelettes
ah bon alors nous nommions nouveau et
petit jaune y ont gelé mais là je monte
un peu manga ce je vais finir 10h et
l'échalote sont très bonnes c'est
échalotes longue que vous avez l'âme est
une nouvelle espèce
et puis on va vite très la sorbonne en
revêtant gagner du temps c'est très bien
live que je vais croiser demain petite
mais influente oui voilà où tout y est
un peu tout charvet tout y est un peu
voilà c'est bien parce que la toile
était bien chaude alors qu'elle rêvait
comme il faut alors maintenant je veux y
mettre du vinaigre aller parce qu'il
faut mouiller avec quelque chose au yen
et là ça fait un tube avec une sauce un
peu piquant à peu relevé la rapidité
caramélisées regarder sur fond
aujourd'hui je vais mettre mes tomates
que j'ai coupé en petits morceaux ou
regarder ça c'est joli c'est des petits
riens qui arrange pas mal de bonnes
petites choses c'est facile à faire
c'est très très fasciné santé sas et
bras coûteux non
et à la portée de tout le monde c'est
tout les cornichons a voulu découper les
couper en rondelles que je n'y vois là
il m'en reste euros je vais le coupé à
faire un plat comme vous dites qu'il
fonctionne pas la gaspiller t'invite à
manger avec la santé
je vous connais à la gorge un petit peu
mais c'est bon on a su mijoter tous à 90
sur le monde allait en faire d'ailleurs
si on va les remettre mais on les laisse
la voilà je fais fiche comme dit un peu
de sel de poivre et je vais faire en
afrique ont très peu dessus qu'ils vont
finir de cuire tout doucement
cb l'iphone demande à ce que le fort il
faut que je sois très cuir lui qui fait
qu'il faudra au moins un quart d'heure
nos bien tassés plus les foyers non mais
là c'est vraiment surveiller
voilà laurent je vais bien c'est mon gas
et on l'a fait on couvrait pas en
battant 15 minutes ont passé voilà et
c'est terminé et sera pratiquement
terminé oui il n est pas seul assiette
je vais sortir mais qu'aucun donc non
éligible à s'étendre comme le rose
là je les mets de côté deux côtés il va
demeurer là où par nord
alors là on goûte oui et c'est super les
goûts avec le bout des doigts un peu
acide moi ce serait bien mais on va
rajouter quand même autre chose va y
mettre un peu de porter ça c'est pour
ceux qui n'aiment axa re voilà que ce
soit l'acidité
mais c'est bon quand même alors un grand
soupçonne en on n'a pas beaucoup envie
après je vais y mettre un petit peu de
crème fraîche la regarder ça dans notre
beau pays
jolie petite foule aux pieds le rendent
parfois je vous dis pas je me doute
ouais d'un crème fraîche pour épaissir
un petit peu cette hausse pour la rendre
plus voluptueuse
là il n'est pas la cuillère en bois si
si mais je touche écrasant même temps
tout ce qui reste de dur
et vous allez voir et vous remettez les
gouttes encore un couard oui oui parce
que les cotes il faut qu'elle reprenne
tout ce monde parfait là allez-y vous
les remettez de rands hermé on s'amusait
mais là pas longtemps parce qu'elles
sont cuits non cela s'est passé samedi
là et là c'est prêt à présenter après là
c'est terminé c'est là on gaspille et
pas aux autres est alors en métaux on ne
jette rien voilà et dans 5 minutes on
présente nos deux plats terminé c'est
fini le mariage l'aquitaine et le
danemark peut paraît très réussi très
bien ce sont des normes européennes sans
peut continuer alors on a notre atypique
et de coups de gérance comme ça les
pommes les kiwis qui sont de chez nous
d'autres experts tous un peu car à mi
moyens sont bons délicieux et puis alors
le coach a pu faire je vous dis pas ça
c'est excellent aussi d'un accès
amélioré et délicieux pas cher alors là
vous n'avez aucune excuse pour ne pas
essayer c'est pas cher c'est ultra
facile mais tu as fait quand même de
trouver du port des aldudes ça sera
encore meilleure au revoir à bientôt à
des chasses
[Musique]